our inaugural round in clinical
epidemiology oh it is you try saying
that three times quickly it gives me
great pleasure to actually introduce
this series because it represents an
evolutionary step in the growth of new
mics in the department we have grown and
added to our training program so that we
not only have certificates masters PhD
pre and post doctoral programs but also
now starting this year a ACGME certified
clinical informatics subspecialty
program and our our first cohort of two
fellows inho and Jim are here amongst us
we are one of a handful of programs
offering subspecialty certifications in
clinical informatics and as we have
grown by adding to our educational
component exponentially we've also grown
in adding to the kind of learning
opportunities that are available to
folks at v-- mics and in addition to our
regular didactic components are
extremely large course catalog the
thursday research conferences that we
have I'm very pleased to report that we
are also adding a monthly series of
clinical informatics Pacific Grand
Rounds that are patterned on the ACGME
medical Grand Rounds of clinical
specialties and therefore similar to
other medical Grand Rounds at OHSU we've
applied for it successfully received
permission to offer CME credits up to
one hour of a MapR rating category one
CME credit for physicians who would like
to take up avail of this opportunity for
each of these grand round offerings and
so I'd like to thank some folks at CMA
Michelle Pfeiffer or associate dean for
professional development and lifelong
learning
Lesley during Alex Carter with GME who
were in
missile and getting our proposal through
and of course here at demise
Andrea L and Lynch Wahby who have been
kind of instrumental in making sure that
the administrative component of this of
this grand round series has come to
fruition and so if anyone who is here or
listening online is interested in
obtaining CME credit if you're here then
Lynn has some paperwork for you and if
you're online you can email her at SW s
c HW ABT l at OHSU dot edu she can set
you up for the process of CME and if any
of you are online and have questions
during Bill's presentation you can
always tweet to us at at OHSU
Informatics and that hashtag is hashtag
email conf so now with the housekeeping
out of the way it is my pleasure to
introduce our inaugural speaker for this
series of clinical informatics Grand
Rounds I didn't have to travel far I
just got out of my office went up the
stairs knocked on his door it's really
imperative as a chair most of you know
him I'm going to very very briefly
introduce him he trained in medicine at
the University of Illinois in Chicago
stay in Chicago for his internal
medicine residency at the University of
Illinois Hospital and then went to
Boston for formal medical informatics
fellowship at Harvard and then in 1990
he came to OHSU and it's really
interesting to see how there's such a
parallel between the growth of V mice
and informatics at OHSU and the growth
of informatics as a discipline in the
United States and the great experiment
that has come out of all of this so no
one is in a better position to talk to
us about this great experiment then
build was been at the center of it for
so many years
thanks Vishnu and I too want to welcome
everyone
to clinical informatics grandma's test
those of you who have been around know
and I'm glad the camera can capture the
fact that no one was near me here but
anyways as you know I historically kind
of given the first talk in our
conference series each year and decided
to do that again this year and and then
also where as mission you mentioned
launching our clinical informatics Grand
Rounds which is one of the things that
you do when you become a medical
specialty or subspecialty but reflecting
the fact that the our clinical
preventive spell OSHA is really part of
our larger program and I've always
wanted it to be that way it's very
important for it to be that way we
decided to insert it in this conference
series much in the way that we exert the
implemented discovery lab talks on a
periodic basis in this as well so once a
month or so we will be doing that
clinical informatics Grand Rounds we're
also going to be offering continuing
medical education or CME credit for
physicians particularly those who are
among the 787 board-certified clinical
informaticians now who will be needing
to keep up in their field so so for the
oftentimes I'm kind of just sort of give
them an overview of the field but in the
program but this year I got to take a
look back and in particular I actually
went back and as you'll see on some of
my slides pull down some of my own
writings and I don't own my own
statements and using that to kind of
look back and we're really at this
turning
point now where essentially the
high-tech Europe is drawing to a close
and what lies ahead for informatics I I
hope I've convinced you that it's a
pretty optimistic picture although there
is obviously some problems that we need
to overcome these slides as always
there's a PD app including all the
references on my website right here at
the top or email me up send them to them
as well for those of you out in
cyberspace we will be watching the
Twitter feed and if there is watching it
but I will watch it too as I usually do
in the conference's and they'll be happy
to answer any questions that come in
that way I'm actually trying to keep the
talk a little on the shorter side to
leave time for questions although we are
off to a slightly late start due to the
different location today
but anyways when you join the continuing
medical education world they have to do
things like disclosures so I have to
disclose that I have no stocks or
anything like that
although I always point out I teach
informatics for a living so I'm even
that's a conflict of interest but
hopefully not Oh Hsu is accredited by
the ACCME
to provide CME credit and is available
to physicians who wish to obtain it in
CMA type talks one must provide learning
objectives explicitly and so here is
what you all saw in the email that Lynne
sent around just talking about the
thirty billion dollar investment in
hi-tech the grand experiment as I called
it in 2010 and here we are five six
years later here with the results in so
we'll describe the rationale for the
investment
the beneficial and problematic results
and then discuss moving forward so I'm
actually going to present my talk like
the way that we tell all the trainees to
write scientific papers with an
introduction the introduction I'll talk
about some of the problems and solutions
that we talked about for the electronic
health record the methods of this study
were the implementation of the high tech
Act
I'll show you some of the results and
then wrap it up with some discussion on
moving forward so a decade ago we knew
that there were a lot of problems in
healthcare that informatics could
contribute towards solving the IOM
report it seems like ages ago but back
around 2000 came out the so-called
errors report that documented anywhere
from 48 to 96 thousand deaths per year
due to medical errors some people are
going to do well some are it's too high
but no one arguing that there were
safety problems in health care in
medicine
the famous McGlynn study in 2003 showing
that patients only got about 55% of the
care that they should be getting if they
were treated by best practices known at
the time the cost issues both the cost
of health care but also the constant
like trying to help records of studies
in the early to mid 2000s one noting
that there at that time was a clear
class return on investment for
electronic health records but that
returned in to go to the people who made
the investments which is part of the
motivation for the high tech Act the
physician practices making the
investments and the insurance companies
in the laboratory is actually getting
the financial benefit and then also
another modeling study modeling studies
always have limitations but showing or
showing at least in this
that widespread interoperability of
electronic health records could save the
health care system around 77 billion
dollars per year that study coming from
the RAND Corporation we also knew at the
time that physicians had challenges
accessing information a study coming out
of Iowa finding that 44% of ambulatory
visits resulting in a piece of
information that being obtainable by the
physician and so this were some of the
rationales for investing the electronic
health records so what was the solution
interoperable health care records some
of you remember 10 years ago when I had
the opportunity to be on NPR and Ira
Flatow stock donation and along with
esteemed dr. Lucy bleep and dr. Joel
Heyman and we talked about the state of
the art at the time none of us could
really foresee hi-tech at the time the
government was investing millions and
not billions and we all recognized that
somehow that if we wanted to achieve the
benefits that investment need to be
higher other benefits for electronic
health records are the so-called
secondary use the seminal ami a white
paper on the value of secondary use or
reuse of data and electronic health
records and then implementing the
learning health system a concept put
forth by the Institute of Medicine that
we need to do a much better job with the
medicine of learning from what we do
pointing to examples in the airline
industry of nuclear power industry and
so forth so this is what I said on that
show you can actually still go listen to
the mp3 or not one of the transcript
what we have now is the most is that
most transactions in healthcare take
place on paper it's not true anymore but
it was
whether it's facts or slips of paper and
this leads to medical errors duplication
and so forth what we're advocating is
replacing the traditional paper charting
of its problems with the electronic one
it will now not solve all the problems
in medicine but will go a long way
towards solving some so we were very
optimistic to 2005 XE here earlier I had
the opportunity to write a an editorial
in JAMA the famous Journal and some of
you have seen this slide before looking
at the reasons why we had not achieved
better adoption of all kinds of health
information technology the cost again
not so much the cost of investment but
the mismatch between who pays and who
benefits some of the technical
challenges not so much really technology
problems but things like usability and
operability things like that
interoperability big one I made mention
a privacy and confidentiality not really
knowing how big this issue was going to
be and I'll talk about that a little bit
and then because of my interest in
educating people I raised the issue that
we don't have the workforce to
potentially benefit to take advantage of
the technology that's available then
2009 came we had a new president the
economy was tanking and we needed an
economic stimulus and certainly
something that was kind of shovel ready
for economic stimulus would be to invest
in electronic health records and as he
said right before inauguration to
improve the quality of our health care
when lowering cost will make the
investments needed to ensure that within
five years that was last year all of
America's medical records are
computerized it just won't save billions
of dollars and thousands of jobs and the
thought saving thousands of jobs I
thought what's important it will save
lives by reducing
deadly and preventable medical errors
that pervade our healthcare system this
led to the health information for
technology health information technology
for economic and clinical Health or high
tech Act which mainly consists of
incentives for adoption of electronic
health records at the time they said up
to twenty seven billion but we've next
exceeded that and then the number of
grants from federal agencies for
Workforce Development Regional Extension
centers and so forth and about two
billion total including one hundred
eighteen million dollars for workforce
which was anyone in the room was a
beneficiary of that but our department
certainly was and I think we gave really
great contributions with the investment
and when high tech was born I proclaimed
in my blog which some of you read then
informatics lives in a high-tech world
in fact a few years ago when I gave this
introductory talk that's what I said and
I talked about the that was the title of
the talk the flurry of activity laid out
is immense and I also said this this is
a defining moment for the informatics
field so this is in early 2010 never
before has such money and attention been
lavished on it high tech provides a
clear challenge to the field to get it
right dude we will talk about that it
will be interesting to look back on this
time in the years ahead
that's now and see what worked and did
not work whatever does happen it's
that informatics now lives in a
high-tech world so what did high tech
actually do I think probably most of you
know for the few that might not provided
incentives for the so-called meaningful
use of electronic health records this
required eligible hospitals and eligible
professionals to meet various criteria
in certain stages stages one two and
three using EHR technology that had been
certified by process specified by the
government adhering to certain standards
that in retrospect were probably not
didn't go erna and have the ability to
measure and send quality measures as
well as enabled health information
exchange the movement of data across
business boundaries in health care and
if you look at this slide you can make
the case that hi-tech was
extraordinarily successful whether it's
whether it's physicians in their offices
around 2009 to now with any EHR or
having some basic set of functions
emergency departments outpatient
departments and probably the biggest
success of law is in hospitals so nearly
every hospital in the United States at
this point has a certified electronic
health record system they haven't all
achieved on the meaningful use criteria
but from that standpoint
Meaningful Use has been successful I
could just kind of end my talk here and
celebrate but there have been some
problems and now I'll go through these
in the next few slides interoperability
hasn't quite worked as well as people
hoped there's been a particularly
adverse impact on workflow we have this
kind of conundrum around structured
versus unstructured data usability
problems problems with safety of health
IT we have we touted as I
back in 2005 on NPR that that we would
improve safety in health care which we
probably have but we've also introduced
new challenges and then security issues
which I alluded to in a moment so what's
what's happened with interoperability
the how could we possibly have installed
electronic health records in every
hospital in the country yet they cannot
easily talk to each other there are some
exceptions actually number of exceptions
but there's no kind of universal
communication we there is a number of
reasons for this one is the incomplete
adoption of standards and the Jayson
report was put out for O&C
that criticized the lanta of some of the
modern EDI based approaches that we use
to send information around the Internet
sexy Lent ONC to establish the Jayson
task force to respond to its
recommendations and there's been some
good to come out of that
a more recent well something has been
around a while but documented more
recently as this notion of information
blocking not it's not so much a
technical issue yes it is a business
issue and for a variety reasons health
care systems do not health care systems
sometimes block sending information to
each other sometimes it's due to the
cost that it would take to implement the
ability to exchange information so
that's one problem I am I was joking
XM's in a seminar for our fellows
earlier this morning and they put up
this slide and I was joking that you
can't give an informatics
without showing this picture this
picture was published in JAMA the famous
Journal and it was drawn by a
nine-year-old who was seeing her
position with her family and it's very
telling that she's sitting on the exam
table and interacting with presumably
and another sister or her mother her
baby sister and there's all these houses
on the community and what's the doctor
doing over here this is clearly a
problem there's other problems as well
there's concerns that there's some too
much focus on the computer rather than
the patient there's a paper published
earlier this year called writing the
wrong that talks about that
there's a famous radiologist is he and
his father is also radiologist and
accused him of leading to the demise of
radiology rounds when I was a medical
student a resident one of the stops
during our day at least once a day was
to the radiology department and you'd
sit around with the radiologist and
review your films well we don't need to
do that anymore just like I guess in a
sense we don't need for this number of
people who didn't show up here today
maybe than watching at their desk being
the senior doctor chain found that his
son had led to really the demise of
reviewing films and some of the nuances
and things like that because now you
just get the report you get the the
image itself on your workstation on your
ward you don't have to go down to the
radiology department and this
facilitates work around some like the
copy and paste problem which may be some
one is called sloppy and pasted where
people copy and paste electronic text
and sometimes propagating things that
are wrong this was exeunt but now
first documented by one of our former
trainees dr. Peter MD who did his
fellowship about ten years ago
he's now vice chair and the informatics
department at Ohio State and this
problem has come to be known and there's
lots of concerns about it although some
part of you that historically that's
what we've done we've looked at
yesterday to know things look we're
saying that's what we write there might
be a role for propagating information
but not just that I can apply and copy
and paste sort of way
there's huge concerns about usability of
electronic health records there's a this
study from the Hoos called American EHR
noting that satisfaction of EHRs seems
to be on the decline from previous years
when people weren't given meaningful use
incentive dollars to adopt them part of
this is due I think to a problem with
medical data and something that I don't
think we can blame on the vendors or the
government or anyone else but that's
something I've been concerned about is
great excitement about structured data
that's and they like trying to help
record and all the secondary uses which
I mentioned in a previous slide we can
do with it
the problem is physicians don't like
structured data they what if they're
entering the data they want to tell the
story if they're reading the data they
want to read this story and I've had
many physicians that's when I say
personal communications here I don't
have a actual reference for this
although I'm sure I could easily find
something but many physicians you know
when I tell them what I do you know they
start complaining at me and one of the
big things is you know I don't trust
medical records anymore they're
especially medical
that are checkboxes and things like that
I want to know the story
this one that I'm writer few years ago
saying patients don't speak template
patients come in with a story there's
lots of nuances and so I think this is
one area that I think we just
underestimated how difficult it was
gonna be just a conundrum that's why I
can't think of a better word to describe
it
between structured and unstructured data
and something that we're going to have
to figure out going forward
well natural language processing play a
little bit maybe but but even this issue
aside there are still usability problems
and there was a study published just a
few weeks ago in JAMA that talked about
vendors not adhering to rules that
they're supposed to adhere to about
usability testing and so forth in their
products I think that vendors could be
doing a better job on usability I also
think that electronic health records are
a very complicated piece of software and
as much as you know we love our phones
and easy to use applications that
medical records are complicated and I
think we're going to have to deal with
that another kind of thing relating to
usability is this report that was done
by the RAND Corporation for the AMA
looking at things that cost position
dissatisfaction with their jobs and
you'll never guess this is 2013 ranked
number one electronic health records
although they did point out physicians
approve of EHRs in concept but that felt
that the current state of EHR technology
is worse and so these are issues that we
have to figure out how to deal with
there's also these safety issues I don't
think anyone really anticipated this the
Joint Commission which accredits
hospitals and healthcare organizations
as these sentinel points that are things
that are really important safety issues
that hospitals should
for two of these alerts in the past
decade have been around health IT safety
the Institute of Medicine published a
report on health IT safety and what we
need to do about it
that report as a chapter from a few Hsu
authors led by Joe Nash how do we what
kind of roadmap do we follow to avoid
what we call a iatrogenic sis and then
there are some well-known recent mishaps
some of you may be familiar with the
book by Bob Walker which is very nice
read and ends despite its kind of
negative tone initially ends in a very
positive way but spends a fair amount of
time talking about a patient at UCSF
we've got a common enemy that
trimethoprim saltbox
you know what that is and 38 times the
dose you know how could that possibly
happen with such a common medication
that we need for urinary tract
infections and then we all know the
story of the Ebola patients in Dallas
who because miscommunication was
discharged home probably expose people
at least to the virus and a report was
recently published on that on some of
the issues there and then there is no
security issue I love this line that was
this in the New York New Yorker your
previous provider used to share your
electronic medical records but not to
worry I was able to obtain all your
information online and the reason why I
say two to one is it highlights two
problems that we have one is the health
exchange health information exchange and
interoperability from that I already
looked into the other problem is the
fact that we can find people's
information online which is a problem
and this year especially has been the
year of the mega breach it started I
think in January Anthem Blue Cross Blue
Shield had 80 million records
compromised premiere Blue Cross 11
million
Excel is BlueCross 10 million records
and there have been many many more a
report just came out from KPMG finding
that 81% of health IT leaders reported
that their systems were compromised in
the last 24 months so this is another
issue that we absolutely have to sell
although it's hardly unique to medicine
maybe some of you are following the
Office of Personnel Management for the
federal government which started as that
thought this might be a 1 million person
breach and now it's up to 5 million
people or those things like fingerprints
and all that database so there are huge
privacy and security issues and since
the most private and confidential
information is in not a corrector it's
something that we need to address so I
gave you that initial grant going on we
were successful then I told you all this
or in the stuff is this like total
despair I'll say no because I'm an
optimist and I tend to think that the
glass is half-full and so we have to
remember that there's still research
that shows the benefit of health IT that
there are emerging models for more
effective use of it
there are various calls to improve
usability and interoperability and
there's a lot of opportunity to really
do good things with electronic health
records especially in areas of data
science and data analytics so there's
plenty of evidence than electronic
health records are providing value to
the delivery of healthcare and patients
this was a systematic review published
last year that was organized around the
meaningful use criteria so there's
actually evidence to support though so
functionality like clinical decision
support health information exchange
e-prescribing etc when you even though
the clinical EPI folks in our department
like the way this is done because you're
not really supposed to count studies but
if you do count studies most of them are
either positive or makes positive so
there is value at least when health IT
is done right there's also people who've
given a lot of thought to using the
computer in the exam room this is a
paper that I went researching this talk
about ways to think about engaging the
patient when they come in for their
visit to not be like that nine year old
room facing the other way and while the
patient is playing with their parents
and baby sister
things like greeting the patient setting
things up so the page made clear the
patient that the computer is there in
the room trying to avoid interrupting
them to turn to the computer and get
engaging them with the screening
oftentimes that usually means turning
the screen around so the patient can see
what you're entering interacting with
them and as you do it and and really
educating them coming along the process
so minimizing straight gaze and trying
to stick with the patient that of course
expressing empathy clinicians should be
doing so I think there's there's hope in
this direction there are a few important
documents that I think point the path
forward or we could be like somebody you
know John palanca and five Wachter who
wrote the digital doctor who basically
say you know it's kind of like Vietnam
let's just declare victory and go home
saying we did break Meaningful Use and
move on but I think there are some
some of these documents are worth taking
a look at so that am a published a paper
and these are all referenced in my PDF
of improving electronic health record
usability really focusing on the
physicians and their participation in
the health care team coordinating care
to focus electronic health records that
way also though talking about promoting
data liquidity making it easy for data
to appropriately move from place to
place and helps would be reused another
one came from India this was released a
few months ago there India had set up a
task force to look at the status and
future directions and things like that
context for the type of their improved
documentation requirements and
functionality to empower patients
refocus regulations ie meaningful use so
that patients and their caregivers can
get the most benefit increasing
transparency in how EHR vendors not
break for example fostering innovation
and supporting person-centered care
another position paper comes from the
American College of Physicians you may
recognize our own Tommy active as one of
the author's here I won't read through
all these but basically talking about
the importance of clinical documentation
with the emphasis on the care of
patients and as much as the secondary
use and all that stuff we want to do I
think at the end of the day it's most
important for electronic health records
to benefit patient care and and then
dealing with the interoperability issue
earlier this year the ONC
released its roadmap for
interoperability and it involves a
number of things
we actually heard last week in our
conference from Keith Boone about the
fast health interoperability resources
our fire standard that's a more modern
way than the older HL southern ways of
moving information moving data back and
forth and XE fire is now an official hl7
standard security things like oh ah -
which probably everyone in this room has
used if you've ever signed up for a
website where you use your Facebook or
LinkedIn login there are modern ways to
do security that can be enhanced in
health care the ONC also is looking at
various other standards terminology
standards things like that and then
pulling this all together in something
called the Argonaut project which
actually comes from the Jason Report and
developing an API and other core data
services based on fire yeah or should we
declare picture and go home this is
about walk thermoses
so I think there's opportunities so I'm
gonna try to finish off on a very
positive note and then I've tried to
make money any time before the question
is both here and remotely so there are
optimists that look at the way we have
increased the amount of data that's
available John dr. Jonathan Berlin who
was at the VA for many years and those
with ACA talks about the data dividend
maybe will use that you know we it's not
as I said in 2005 that everything is
almost completely paper and backspace
transactions we so plenty of that
unfortunately but we've certainly made a
lot of progress and the whole area of
predictive analytics
there was a viewpoint published in JAMA
not too
go talking about how if done right
predictive analytics could help
physicians by helping them better
understand what's going on in their
communities how patients are likely to
respond to treatments and so forth and
the ration now still exists just this
week the Institute of Medicine came out
with its report on diagnostic errors and
how serious they are so we still can use
better information delivered to the mind
of the clinician as they're diagnosing
and treating patients there are still
plenty of therapeutic errors as well so
those rationales for the EHR end and
health IT have not gone away and so
informatics can be part of the solution
and then on the research side we're
undertaking this big precision medicine
initiative that will among other things
required assembling a 1 million patient
cohort and NIH came out with the report
a few weeks ago looking at the things
that were necessary to do that and it's
you know each our mobile devices the
entire mobile devices so clearly there's
still a great rationale for EHRs and
there's also where we need for people
who work in informatics including
physicians and the new clinical
informatics subspecialty but physicians
are not all there is about informatics
there's a plenty of roles for others and
of course data scientists and there's a
report and came across which verifies
some data from a previous report that
it's not only the hardcore data
scientists we need but there's this five
to ten fold universe of people that are
data users and managers that need to
understand informatics data science and
related topics to take
so I think the picture is pretty bright
and so let me conclude at that point by
saying first the meaningful use the
grand experiment has definitely been a
mixed bag
we witnessed substantial adoption as we
saw by those graphs but we also know
that systems are suboptimal could be
better in particular issues of
interoperability so do we blame when I
go to social events and people find out
what I do when they start yelling at me
I think we have some of the blame you
know we were very excited and
enthusiastic maybe a little naive back
at the start of the high tech era so how
do we rectify that well I think we need
to step up and take the leadership and
responsibility and solving some of the
conundrums and at this point I'll stop
and see what you think are some of those
solutions or whether there's any
questions and as I understand it in this
room this microphone will likely capture
unlike our other normal room but speak
loudly and then maybe I'll repeat the
questions anyways and then I'll also
well good so let me thank you and let me
open up to any questions or comments
yeah no I completely agree I mean the
first point you mentioned about
meaningful use was brought but didn't
include every last part of the
healthcare system and especially as we
enter the era of accountable care
organizations where you need to
coordinate all the information I don't
know that meaningful use was ever really
meant to you know bring every last
person on board but clearly there needs
to be ways and hopefully as we move
towards the need for integrated and
coordinated care that that that would
just provide the incentive to bring the
rest of those people along but you're
right and then the issue of standards
and standards are tough you know it's
easy to kind of get up and say you know
we need standard
there's so many of them out there you
know I can't use them but that you know
they're tough and and they don't always
work as you described when when people
try to implement them you know but we
need to do that if we want to make
healthcare more interoperable and
coordinated you know I mean there's
there's a lot of research well I should
say there's a lot there's some research
that has been done and the NEX I'm not
the foremost expert on it but everything
I read seems to think that the critical
thing is to establish the tribe you know
so we're moving from the dyad of the
patient and the physician although I can
certainly remember from my own years of
clinical practice I'd be sitting there
writing in the chart you know with the
patient sitting across from me but
moving to this more kind of triad model
where the patient sees what's happening
in the computer I mean I've seen
physicians who kind of keep the screen
they look at the patient but they're
looking at the screen too and that's
probably not the best way to do it so I
don't know about a particular hardware I
imagine the device needs to be big
enough or at least the screen needs to
be big enough for the patient to see it
you know I'm supposed to showing your
patient your phone or something like
that if you're entering data that way so
so III don't know but III think man
probably the technology the important
thing about the technology is not so
much which technology you use but
something that enables you to engage
with the patient
any other we can go Vinny yeah yeah yeah
well most some people know this the
original HIPAA legislation said that we
will establish a national health
identifier in 1996 and it politically
went over like a lead balloon and you
know we had led to you know people
saying thing oh you know the government
wants to establish a database you know
health care you know of all your health
care which which was not true so yeah
not not having a standard identifier has
been a problem some people say we don't
need it because we're so good at record
matching you know just look at how
Facebook Google can connect you to this
and that but it probably would be made a
little easier
it certainly has you know the potential
to be misused I suspect that the benefit
went outweigh the risk and maybe as
people get more confident in our ability
to keep information secure which they're
not right now understandably that you
know maybe they would be more accepting
of it many other countries use national
identifiers Singapore New Zealand
there's actually a great some you've
taken my classes now there's a great
website about the new New Zealand I
didn't patient identifier I think that's
the exact name of it but they explain
the whole rationale and why it's
important
like that so we'll see what happens with
identifiers yeah yeah I had the
opportunity if I could be king for a day
or if President Obama called me into his
office and say how would you change this
I I think that in retrospect there was
probably not enough emphasis put on
interoperability and I think that many
of the criteria we actually haven't even
seen yet the criteria for stage 3 of
meaningful use there's they're they're
literally at the printers and the
government will be publishing them
there's drafts that have been seeing but
even stage 2 has been very challenging
for healthcare organizations and it also
the one of the challenges with the
meaningful use criteria is they've
they've really stifled innovation in
other areas because everyone you know
the vendors the hospitals the physicians
and others have been so focused on
meeting the criteria that they haven't
really had any bandwidth to do other
kinds of innovative things and for
example I recently was chatting with
someone from Kaiser that was doing EHR
as well before Meaningful Use and was
really for Kaiser he claimed that
Meaningful Use was a big a big waste of
time because they were already already
doing most of that stuff but they had to
make sure that they did enough of it to
get the money so so anyways you know
maybe kind of less prescribed and and
more towards having the functionality
that an agent enables interoperable
systems and the ability to participate
in quality measurement and improvement
programs and things like that would
probably be a way to do it I don't know
that we could have really anticipated
that you know five six years ago you
know it's always easy and
sites to look back but clearly I don't
think we did enough for interoperability
yeah yeah so the question is whether we
have the momentum to keep going or we'll
hit inertia especially around things
like secondary use of data that's a
great question you know I didn't predict
everything right here so I don't know
that I want to go too far out on a limb
I mean it's clear that you know at least
the money part of meaningful use is
ending actually that's not totally true
because the meaningful use was
structured that in the first few years
you get the money and the financial
incentives beyond that are in the form
of penalties if you don't reach
meaningful use and I always thought and
I still believe it's going to happen at
some point some you know the political
process will wipe out those penalties
that they're actually being reformulated
into other healthcare quality programs
some of you may be familiar with this
thing called MIPS not the MIPS we know
from computing but it's something about
different payments around quality
measures and so forth so I so there
there might be some continued penalty
for not meeting meeting meaningful use
but clearly there isn't going to be any
more money going into it
so what will happen I think I think that
probably the best driver of health IT is
actually not you know giving people
money for meaningful use but creating a
healthcare system that that values
integration and coordination of
information a really integration
coordination of care when you move and
you know the Secretary of Health and
Human Services has said that as we go
forward Medicare is going to its
remuneration is going to be more related
to quality the so-called
you over volume moving away from
fee-for-service towards more towards
reimbursement that is more related to
the quality of care you deliver when
when you need to do things like prevent
readmissions to the hospital and deliver
high-quality care to a whole population
information becomes important and that's
what should probably be the best driver
of adoption of EHRs and not you know
giving people money because 60% of their
orders are now electronic and things
like that so it's my thought on that
okay well thank you all for coming to
our inaugural Grand Rounds and